salut tout le monde j'espère que vous
allez bien dans cette vidéo c'est la
suite de notre série sur le gang des
blacksdragon si vous avez pas vu la
première partie je vous recommande
vraiment d'aller la voir pour comprendre
l'histoire qu'on veut raconter dans
l'épisode 2 je pense que vous allez être
surpris de découvrir qu'il y avait pas
que des combattants noirs dans ce groupe
il y avait aussi Chuck tout petit
teasing je vous en dis pas plus bon
visionnage
au revoir
dans les escaliers
toute la nuit je dormais dans les
escaliers j'ai attendu
le matin dès qu'il est ouvert la porte
en fait
je suis pas j'ai pas touché je suis pas
pris son pouls mais après il faut
rencontrer mais faut pas le mettre en
direct
non mais sinon je vais dormir chez eux
aussi
[Rires]
[Musique]
il voulait pas de blanc dans les Black
Dragon
parce que je pensais qu'il fallait être
fallait se mélanger
même un métier ça posait problème
c'était un peu l'époque Black Power
voilà il y avait des groupes de Black
uniquement de constitués de black
à cette époque là les plaques dragons se
battent contre les Blancs le blanc c'est
pas forcément l'image qu'ils ont
positive pour eux le blanc il discrimine
il agresse ils vous empêche d'avancer
j'avais aussi du racisme chez les blacks
j'ai vu des blagues supportaient pas les
Antilles enfin et un moment je me suis
dit c'est quoi ce bordel
surtout quand même je pense à casser
cette idéologie voilà un petit peu trop
sectaire je suis un blanc
un babtou dans une cité où il y a
énormément de rebeu et de renois donc il
y a aussi cette
cette place qu'il faut se faire c'est
pas un racisme anti-blanc c'est vraiment
un problème social où on mélange
énormément de
multiculturelle dans un même endroit
avec tout ce qui véhicule en tant que
pauvreté misère la misère qui a dans les
cité et du coup ça génère ça génère de
la violence
pour commencer
dans les cités de Nanterre c'était des
bidonvilles avant Nanterre 60-70 il y
avait la drogue il y avait le vol il y
avait que des escalier il se ni fait des
sniffer de la colle à rustine dans les
sacs plastiques il y avait la cocaïne il
y avait de l'Hérault il y avait des
overdose il y avait
l'alcool il y avait voilà tout ce qui
est toutes les cités des années 80 en
fait
c'était violent quoi
mais c'est vrai que en tant que blanc
dans une cité
si tu t'en poses pas tu sais manger
[Applaudissements]
je commence la boxe anglaise
mon club de boxe c'est un club de boxe
les Black Panthers qui s'entraînaient
bon je me suis fait je me suis fait
repérer déjà et
là je rencontre des blagues
et du coup moi c'est ça devient mes
potes donc je traîne avec eux c'est un
mec très sympa très intelligent
il frappe et très très fort
il y a quelque chose chez lui qui
[Applaudissements]
de colère certainement qui a alimenté ça
bonhomme le garçon
anglaise voici ça que je retiens de lui
il a eu des points c'était des des
parpaings
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
très vite j'étais un peu assimilé au
babtou des blagues dragons c'est qui
traînait tout le temps c'était le babtou
un peu vénère
moi j'ai grandi avec la terre en noir et
blanc
[Musique]
occasion j'ai découvert le fait un film
de Bruce Lee puis je rêvais de faire de
la boxe des arts martiaux mais mes
parents m'ont mis au foot
[Musique]
et du coup je me sauver du terrain pour
aller dans la cave à six sept ans et
j'essaie de répéter des mouvements
d'arts martiaux donc déjà très jeune
voilà j'avais envie de ça
[Musique]
la plupart d'entre nous on a commencé
les arts martiaux avant même d'être
Black Dragon c'est vraiment de dès
l'enfance on a commencé moi je suis
passé au karaté directement donc à l'âge
de 7 ans j'ai commencé et on
s'entraînait ici au parc de Nanterre
on venait de se confronter aux autres
d'autres sports et surtout on
s'entraîner au combat de groupe
c'est la queue le dragon avec la tête de
des serpents avec le prénom de maman
au parc Nanterre je me rappelle moi de
mon grand frère de mon grand cousin et
moi je suis petit
donc je vois quoi je vois plein de
grands qui sont là en plus et puis en
plus elle va aider c'est que ils ont
tous du matériel c'était professionnel
les garçons c'est-à-dire que je n'avais
plus leurs parents ils viennent avec eux
leur sacs de frappe leur truc et puis
nous on arrive et puis c'est un lieu où
ça se bagarre magnifique magnifique pour
rester toujours auprès au combat en fait
tout simplement et moi je suis gamin et
je vois ça et je me dis [__] mais ils
sont organisés en fait c'est un truc de
fou je suis né dans la boxe française
Full Contact kick-boxing boxe
thaïlandaise j'ai été champion de France
en boxe thaïlandaise on kick-boxing et
j'ai pris des titres en niveau mondial
le parc dentaire c'est le fief du
gangladragon nous on s'entraîner là-bas
pour prouver notre valeur etc pour
montrer que on était capable
il y a plein de sections de gens qui
s'entraînent boxe thaï boxe française
boxe anglaise Kung Fu et puis tu choisis
là ce qui te plaît et tu t'entraines
ça moi ça me plaît et il y a un rite
pour rentrer chez les Black Dragon on
peut appeler ça rit initiatique ou
recrutement c'est la même chose pour
nous tu fais ton intronisation là-bas
c'est à dire que tu veux rentrer dans
les blagues dragons il y a une ronde
tu rentres dans la ronde on te défonce à
5 ou 6 ou 7 ou 8 pour voir ta solidité
pendant 30 ou 30 secondes ou une minute
pour voir si tu as la capacité de
résister si tu as 50 personnes qui
tombent sur toi
[Musique]
faut que tu te relèves faut qu'à la fin
tu te remets debout sur tes jambes
et on le test sur une semaine à peu près
il fait quelques combats c'est pas qu'il
gagne ou qui perdent des combats qui qui
compte c'est que c'est comment est-ce
qu'on porte comment est-ce qu'on porte
vis-à-vis de donc quand tu reçois des
coups quand il est par terre comment
est-ce qu'on porte
je suis resté debout je me posais pas de
question allez c'est le truc c'est de
rester debout donc je m'étais en bout de
fruits des coups et puis si tu finis
bien après ça et si tu t'es encore
l'envie d'y aller et ben tu rentres
Black Dragon voilà c'était ça un peu la
méthode un peu Black Dragon
c'est paradoxe sale ce que je veux dire
mais je dirais que c'était même une
forme d'amour pour nous
ce qui nous domine nous c'est la misère
donc on va trouver l'amour dans un mot
dans un geste dans même une gifle parce
que la fille qu'on vit à ce moment-là
elle est dure elle est dur on a rien
maman elle a pas d'argent papa il est
ouvrier il galère tout le monde galère
les bandes
pour moi c'est une deuxième famille moi
je sors de la DASS tout ça je sors de la
DASS mon père il a buté ma daronne
j'avais dit piges et je suis parti de
l'adage j'avais 17 ans donc j'étais
dehors et pour moi c'est une bande de
copains et c'est devenu ma famille
c'est ce qui te faisait de sentir en vie
on a grandi à la débrouille ma mère elle
travaille elle est femme de ménage et
mon père travaille à Renaud j'ai une
Renault on avait un vélo pour 6 enfin
après on va s'habiller à Tati parce
qu'on a pas d'argent mais donc les rêves
ils sont divisés par deux on va dire
que je les raconte ça aux gens les gens
ils sont choqués moi c'était à cette
époque là on a des petits gâteaux durs
il y avait il y avait des inscriptions
dessus lui elle moi pour c'était des
gâteaux marrons assez épais mais par
contre on le mettait dans le lait il
fallait deux jours pour qu'il fonde le
truc
pour vous dire à quel point le gâteau
c'était pas du gâteau franchement je
vous le mets dans la tête c'est une
pierre le truc c'est du béton armé le
truc et aujourd'hui on retrouve ce
paquet de gâteaux dans le rayon
animalerie
beaucoup il était en précarité le papa
il travaillait pas la maman de
travailler pas et donc le petit il était
obligé de jongler entre deux bouts donc
obligé de voler dans les magasins pour
familier la bouffe à la maison etc
c'est ce qui fait que les gens se
regroupent en général ils créent une
famille il se crée une famille à eux
parce que bon ben ils vont se soutenir
entre eux
parce qu'ils traversent des difficultés
communes je vais chez un ami à moi
c'est un jeune du quartier je vais dire
sans son nom et la grande la plaie Darty
il avait trouvé la technique pour
s'habiller comment il y avait pas de
sous les balcons l'été des gens mettent
leur fringues à sécher sur leur balcon
et on prenait un chat et on jetait le
chat Walco on le sait il s'agrippe au
fringues ça tombe bien récupérer les
fringues on a dépouillé le
surnez Courbevoie Nanterre plutôt
bon ce qu'on veut des fringues
disparaître je m'excuse
mais en tout cas c'est une bonne
technique c'est du business gentil
la défense n'est pas le Bronx mais son
parvis et le terrain de retrouvailles
voir champs de bataille des blagues
dragons c'est de leurs alliés les
blagues dragons les BD seraient une des
deux grosses bandes de Paris et sa
banlieue son fonctionnement est mal
identifié imprévisible les membres et
sympathisants se regroupent tout d'un
coup font une descente et puis plus rien
la défense c'est un quartier qui gère
les milliards du monde et nous on était
une bande de jeunes comme ça qui vient
qui s'installe là qui prend possession
de l'endroit pour nous la défense nous
appartenait
[Musique]
des souterrains on se baladait dans les
sous-sols de la défense
[Musique]
et ça a gêné beaucoup de monde ça gênait
beaucoup de monde en fait des gens
n'étaient pas d'accord de nous voilà et
nous le faisait savoir
[Musique]
c'est beaucoup de bureaux tout ça mais
il y a des gens qui vivent dès que les
gens des bureaux rentrer chez eux
la défense est à nous
on attendait donc vers 18h 19h à partir
de là c'était nous pour nous c'était
magnifique
la défense est le quartier général c'est
notre fief c'est très grand vous pouvez
vous y perdre ça aperçoit
[Musique]
j'ai grandi à la défense
la tour Gambetta
il était au deuxième étage et moi
j'étais au 15e
beaucoup de premier Black Dragon sont de
Nanterre plutôt Courbevoie etc Yves
vient de là
parmi nous mais il y en a qui étaient
prêts à tout pour satisfaire Yves quand
un ordre arrivait on nous dit voilà il
faut descendre là c'est Yves qui le dit
on y va il sait pourquoi c'était lui le
boss il était devant et puis voilà il
articulé les gens et puis il dirigeait
ses troupes d'une main de maître
[Musique]
Yves vive le vent le chef et de la
maîtrise du vaudou
je vais vous dire un secret encore que
beaucoup ne connaissent pas ne savent
pas on a été ses adeptes de la magie
c'est Haïti qui est comme ça
que Yves le vent là cette capacité de
disparaître mais seul ceux qui l'ont vu
que le savoir c'est pour ça qu'on l'a
surnommé le vent un exemple on est dans
une impasse on peut aligner à gauche ni
à droite le type il disparaît
vive le vent sa magicien
[Musique]
vous voulez voir c'est un magicien c'est
à dire que contrôle de police il a une
arme de sur lui alors je sais pas si je
peux le dire mais il a une arme sur lui
et puis contrôle il y a plus d'armes
on se dit moi qu'est-ce qu'il y a dans
mes côtes
on dit ouais mais c'est de la magie
c'est du vaudou il fait quoi je
comprends pas et lui il avait un livre
plein de dragon qui crée avec son sang
à chacun ses croyances mais il s'appelle
Yves le vent pour toutes ces raisons
vous vous l'avez vu disparaître comme ça
moi je dirais pas ce que j'ai vu mais
j'ai vu beaucoup plus que ça de cet
homme
[Musique]
voilà j'espère que ça vous a plu je
rappelle que l'épisode final est d'ores
et déjà disponible dans la brut sinon je
vous donne rendez-vous ici sur la chaîne
Youtube de brut dans deux semaines merci
encore pour tous vos commentaires tous
vos messages on les lis ça nous fait
super plaisir à très vite